je veux la crète
et non inclus
ne riez pas c'est l ampoule à led de ce
trouble donc en partant par ici
rejoindre itinéraire qui se retrouvent
qui sera en forêt ici
à
surtout ça
est ce que tu as vraiment pas de trop
rien de bien détrôner rien de trop ce
soir fait le point puis tony
virtuellement au début c'était lourd
c'est vrai après au milieu de la balade
ça allait encore on les sentait puis
après la fin de la balade le sentier
mais c'est surtout la fatigue aussi
sommet de cette montagne ces trois là où
hélas elles abattront là ça me paraît
loin et haut et je dis qu'après il ne
faut pas partir lendemain des ça
m'étonnerait
regardez moi qui ai le vertige pour moi
c'est une grande première d'avoir
franchi ce cap quoi
je
allez
j'ai fermé les yeux je suis parti je
dors mystère bien mais par contre l'âge
enfant dé 12 ans à 4 qui est un problème
clé donc choisi s'arrêter et c'était
jeanne qui prenais mes copines donner un
classement google a arrêté des doigts et
on fait passer pour quelqu'un d'autre
stéphanie je passais qu'elle écoutait de
la musique en fait c'était quelqu'un
assis sur le lit ce matin comme ça alors
ça va alléger le moindre bruit en fait
de leur vie
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une superbe tenue
de soirée ah non oui mais non on est
bien d'accord mais c'est doré est
complètement c'est le pantalon de
rechange qu'il fallait emmener oui oui
même les chaises ont été renversés temps
elle a peu la cour eut donc la pénombre
un peu bon avec leur âge bien entendu
depuis ce terrain qui est un petit peu
avec des touffes d'herbes des pierres
donc elle n'a pas vu un trou est la
chute est donc tout de suite on a vu que
c'était fait mal an quelque chose qu est
ce que c est atteint j'ai mis de la
crème
dernier cas d'un plantoir génial
strapping ouais je crois va sans dire
que si une ampoule ou deux ans pourrait
finalement avec le strap mais très vite
et longtemps d'oublier l'entourent oui
ouais ouais ça me permet surtout
continuez donc si voilà j'ai eu
plusieurs problèmes de santé j'ai eu des
grosses opérations et donc bon il faut
dans le monde je fasse assez attention
et et que pour moi non pour moi je
je croque la vie à pleines dents et que
c'est pas les problèmes de santé qui
vont m'arrêter à mes parents à mes
enfants surtout à leur montrer que ben
voila je suis rapide maman non plus et
puis ils ont ma fille à sharon à 9 ans
et demi et mon fils ruben à sept ans et
demi vie de petite amie
oui on était très content que je parte
fiers de leur maman et je veux que ça
continue comme ça qu'ils soient fiers de
moi et qui voit là
encore hier c'est vrai que j'ai une
confiance s'est installée dans le niveau
général du groupe donc on va dire est ce
vraiment parti un peu plus dedans on va
dire plus vite mais hier matin
mais là je vois que le groupe a trouvé
son rythme qui peut donc pas jouer à
nicolas contraint de passer en tête donc
tout va bien mais c'est surtout de
profiter de ce chaos tour le malgré la
météo je pense qu'on va voir plein de
choses différentes aujourd'hui et ça
l'est c'est aussi qu'on serait capable
demandeurs vous là franchement vous
poser dans un coin sec et et je peux
faire une sieste son souci je suis
vraiment très fier j'ai eu très peu de
sauver cette nuit mais je pense que
quand je serais vraiment très très
fatiguée j'entendrai plus rien mais là
ce matin j'ai le souffle court un petit
peu l'attesté tour on avait perdu
deborah mais dans la courbe des fans ils
nous disaient que mon ampoule gauche lui
faisait mal donc on regarde et on a
réajusté la chaussette quand vous aussi
de jouer sur le serrage aussi des
chaussures pour connaître ce témoin
d'une telle ampoule dans tous les cas et
percé depuis hier soir c'est la phase
douloureuse candidats stéphanie ce matin
que visait à arrêter d'être en tongs
aujourd'hui à la plage plutôt qu'à la
paix sous la pluie le brouillard quand
même si bien s'ils entendent peut-être
mais non pas la plage mais je viens même
s'il pleut c'est bien on en bonne
compagnie et où donc c'est bien alors
moi ce que je propose pour la pluie
c'est que là on va continuer qu'on va
faire la pause on va dire qu'à de
la matinée en s'initiant à savoir en
abri sous un auvent de maisons closes
comme ça plutôt qu'ici au milieu des
pâturages habitants
dimanche
un souvenir parce que déborah est
adorable d'abord et ensuite bal est
super sympa comme toulalan afin de
récupérer fait partie des trucs
ouais super des fraises à poney et tout
camarade c'est une géniale dans l'air
bien mûres voir et y aura des fraises
pour toi sur la fraise des bois c'est
vrai que c'est les fruits des bourdes on
va vous mettre en garde sur le fait
qu'on peut quand même contracté sur
intel mic tinoco cause que j'ai compté
il ya quatre c1 mais jour dire
exactement de leurs autographes
exactement fait ça s'apparente assez
directement quelque chose qui
s'attaquent fois en fait tout simplement
et je connais quelques personnes au
moins deux geeks ont subi m ensuite ce
genre de choses merci jean pour le geste
merci qu'il en fin de l'été des fraises
il nous donne ce bien sombre d'illégale
par fatigue
il faut en profiter tant que les shops
est solide bon pour les animaux parce
qu'ils les animaux n'aime pas les bons
bon alors nous notre notre spécialité
c'est le tourisme etc 1 comme l'a dit
guy des chevaux des mules et des ânes
donc c'est pas tourisme équestre
seulement ses comptes et clean un petit
peu tout ce qui se fait avec des avec
des équidés alors là on part avec des
années des mules ce que l'on va faire
c'est donc on doit assurer le transport
de vos bagages avec les animaux donc vos
bagages c'est ce que vous avez sur le
dos il va falloir qu'on s'organise
peut-être on va commencer par ça pour
voir de quelle manière certains sacs
peuvent tenir dans les sacoches et si ça
tient pas on verra pour les fixés
différemment
après on s'occupera des animaux des âmes
vous aurez un ami pour deux personnes
ils sont à l'intérieur
le battage c'est le fait de m
le bas sur le dos et ses arts mais pour
que les sacoches tienne et puis partira
puis on apprendra un petit peu à
manipuler les animaux au fil des
kilomètres
brossard vallée d'olt si la voiture est
un peu comme moi
vite pour montrer qui est le patron puis
c'est tout
pour la remettre
blast sa force de
hu
alors il ya combien de places si ça et
on en est cette leucémie lui évite à
quoi on va trouver une solution va c'est
pas possible donc on va voir on va bien
voir ce que l'on en fait ils peloter sûr
que ça sera moins agréables en attend
est bon c'est ça ou nuit blanche même si
la tente
même si la yourte a l'air très
confortable de le chauffer tout fou que
je dors nos trois nuits annoncé déjà eu
du mal
ce matin là me remettre dans le bain
vous savez beaucoup dans l'après-midi
une troisième nuit sans dormir possible
absolument trouver une solution
combien ça coûte
c'est vrai qu'elle a peiné toute la
journée dès le matin donc en plus elle
faisait partie de ceux qui ont très mal
dormi donc ça a ajouté à ce problème de
santé
je me suis dit bon de toute façon ça va
passer voilà je suis fatigué je
récupérerai plus tard mais finalement ça
va suffire
un petit souci de santé rien de grave on
va faire un examen médical et voir si je
peux continuer avec vous
importante ce soir on est tous là sauf
deborah bien entendu où l'avait vu donc
déborah et est allé voir un médecin ce
soir elle doit donc passer un autre
examen demain matin nous avons donc on
est une étape qui j'avais mesuré à 16 km
et vont nous mener ben comme ça vous
pouvez m'a dit l'avenir donc en partant
par ici revendiquer navale qui sera qui
sera en forêt ici une variante du gène 9
ans et on en dire en direction de la
joue sans aller au village exactement
il
toi tu vas ou hydraulique avec toi oh my
quand je peux petit claque pas des
princes mois avec qui offre avec toi
aller qu'il est tout à fait c'est pas
possible
plus
ballu ouais ça va du kinder
les conditions n'étaient pas encore
réunies mais aussi approche
ok pas de bruit ça c'est sûr et il est y
êtes quand même froid on est bien dans
les hauts plateaux du raf a pas tout
jamais un truc je les ai découvertes
hier soir nalement mes chaussettes qui
était déjà mouillé depuis 11 heures du
matin je n'avais pas sentie et donc je
les ai un peu soignée comme ça j'ai
laissé sécher puis ce matin j'ai mis un
pansement spécial mais en le mettant
dans la yourte avec la lampe de poche
j'en ai mis un très bien et l'autre
limite
bon alors mais j'ai mis à un autre à
côté ça valait bas cette troisième
journée on attaque comme très bonne
position que le soleil revient dans la
brume un peu de brouillard tenace mais
le le soleil terre ce détail est donc le
moment je cours le temps pour la majeure
partie de la journée
on va partir bas principalement en forêt
ce matin et se retrouver mais n'est ce
pas ce que vous dégagez cet après midi
donc en direction de lamoura
ça ce sont des chanterelles
alors certains les appellent des jo note
est une manière aussi de protéger les
reins en se mettant à genoux mais ce
soir on va les cuisiner toute manière
j'ai dû j'ai encore du beurre dans mon
sac dont c'est déjà utile ou trouvera
des à un an
une manière pour les cuisiner une
gamelle même sur le petit à feu doit on
y arrive
quatre garçons se détend la tuer des
cochons normalement quand ils passent
par dessus ça se vaut je laisse à tenir
et ensuite le relais là dans les zones
de pâturage bon ce qu'il va difficile
c'est que la hausse est boueux les bêtes
le click in peace devient parfois
difficile à difficile à marcher donc on
va contourner largement qu'il ya
beaucoup île magnifique fourmilière tout
le monde a vu je pense là évidemment je
m'accroche rihanna ou sol elle est en
pleine activité est là le soleil à mon
avis là après deux jours un petit peu
pas de chômage mais on vient vous
invitez simplement venir accrocher ce
qu'ils veulent la main
rien qu'au dessus vous le dirai ce que
sa famille ou ses choix chalet sochaux
normalement on sent une odeur de
vinaigre dire comment dire oui à une
impression et puis c'est tout simplement
fait ce qu'on appelle l'acide formique
parce que là en s'approchant les ailes
sont une réaction un peu de défense et
ses quatre sets
cet acide
on fait recette
prenez rien arranger on avait perdu des
bras hier comme si une des personnes que
j'apprécie plus ça fait aussi inciter à
m'exprimer avec les autres donc on vise
à shediac bien content que deborah soir
ça revenus selon télé
non mais je pense qu'on était un peu
fatigué qu'on avait faim et voilà mais
si on est super contents de ce soir déjà
qu'on va commencer l'aventuré ensemble
donc on a terminé on est on est on est
très content bien sûr mais un petit peu
surpris beaucoup je n'ai pas fait trop
attention
on voit les pistes de ski alpin de lélex
on ne voit pas directement l'hébergement
pour autant on est à moins de 5 km de
l'hébergement le viage qu'on aperçoit en
bas s'appelle la joue et nous allons
aller entre le village de la jouer le
village de lamoura donc l'amour à cette
départ d'une course de ski de fond c'est
l'homme qui va jusqu'à au village de
mouthe qui permet de dire qu on a fait
l'amour à mouthe de riez pas surtout
c'est bon et
ah bon
ap pu eux
je voudrais différence entre
l'impression que plus vous descendez
plus c'est fort je suis un peu plus bas
même les cocos bien parlants français
oui oui dans ceux là où il ya les trois
s'attache à deux derrière de ce secteur
la wii par là où vous êtes un peu à
gauche du sapin on a l'impression et
puis par contre quand je vais pas si
simon a l'impression qu'il est aussi et
du coup j'ai l'impression que quand du
coup je me déplace vers vous il ya moins
des coûts par contre ce qu'on appelle
une résonance ça veut dire que l'écho en
fête il faut qu'à peu près 20 mètres de
différence entre la somme des missions
et à défendre et puis le ski va envoyer
le son l'obstacle
lula qui en fait la forêt et puis la
roche
pas pour le fret matin de bonne heure ok
là on n'a qu'une envie c'est de nous
laver de poser là quand et de se reposer
mois
du coup n'a pas beaucoup d'amateurs